c'est toujours difficile parce qu'on
passe d'un projet à une réalisation
la réalité elle n'est pas toujours
proche de ce que l'on avait plus qu elle
se serait donc c'est toujours un petit
peu difficile mais c'est toujours aussi
c'est toujours aussi excitant finalement
de vivre cette première année dans le
public que nous nous accueillons on se
trouve avec des porteurs de projets qui
ont un vrai savoir faire technique mais
qui pour autant non pas automatiquement
globalement beaucoup de cultures
d'entreprise et donc ça veut dire
qu'effectivement il faut les accompagner
sur cet aspect gestion qui est
finalement très très important le
premier conseil restera bien évidemment
de gérer au plus sérieux de vendre au
mieux de faire attention à ces coups à
ses marges et ses mais il faut pas
oublier la fonction administrative qui
peut être très importante et qui parfois
laissé de côté au profit de la
production j'ai envie de leur dire que
créer c'est quelque chose de très
prenant ça peut paraître très difficile
mais c'est réalisable
créer son emploi c'est aussi une
solution à l'insertion